la controverse à présent autour de la
commémoration de la rafle du vel d'hiv
applaudissements et sifflets hier soir
pour françois mitterrand lors des
cérémonies du 50e anniversaire du drame
colère de robert badinter
la question de la reconnaissance
officielle de la persécution des juifs
sous le régime de vichy divise philippe
denis et virginie de la haute maison
ce geste n'est pas seulement solennel il
est aussi important
cinquante ans après la rafle du vél vive
organisée par les autorités françaises
le président de la république déposent
une gerbe sur l'ancien site du vélodrome
en compagnie d'une femme rescapé de la
rafle pour mieux souligner l'importance
de cette commémoration les plus hauts
personnages de l'état sont aussi
présents pourtant quelques minutes plus
tôt françois mitterrand a été sifflé dès
son arrivée la déclaration du président
le 14 juillet selon laquelle la
république n'est pas comptable des actes
de vichy n'est pas passé auprès d'une
partie de la communauté juive dérapage
dans l'assistance
plus tard
ses cris ont indigné la majorité de
l'assistance jean kahn président du
conseil représentatif des institutions
juives puis robert badinter viennent à
la tribune exprimé leur colère
je me serais attendu à tout et prouver
sauf le sentiment que j'ai ressenti
il y a un instant et que je vous livre
avec toute ma force d'hommes
vous avez fait vous avez été aux
opposants à ce qui s'est passé là vous
n'avez ferron il y à des mamans oui lady
dans la parole les morts simone veil a
elle aussi condamné les dérapages mais
tout en espérant que le président de la
république fasse un jour un geste
d'apaisement envers la communauté juive
l'état français est il responsable de sa
parenté ce pétainiste voici une opinion
parmi d'autres celle d'un gaulliste
fidèles il n'est pas possible de
d'inculper la france ça ne se fait pas
c'est pas le rôle d'un président de la
république en tout cas il l'a compris
bon ben il la fait pas on l'a pro même
si les jeunes gens ne l'approuvent pas
il faut les instruire un peu mieux que
ce que c'est qu'une république